[Musique]
comme vous pouvez le constater je suis
pas venu seul ce soir
en tant qu'artiste fallait bien que je
vienne avec une oeuvre
mais avant de vous la présenter je
voudrais juste vous dire deux petites
choses extrêmement rapidement c'est que
cette oeuvre a complètement est
entièrement changé ma vie et pourtant je
les réaliser en un temps record alors
sans plus attendre découvrons là tanin
un miroir avec écrit champion du monde
you will do it c'est ma maman qui l'a
écrit ce n'est pas moi pourquoi alors je
vais vous l'expliquer revenons-en
qu'elle revenons quelques années en
arrière
en 2011 je participe à mes premiers
championnats du monde de body painting
et pour la petite anecdote je termine
avant dernier j'ai décidé d'y retourner
chaque année je progresse de + en + 2012
2013 2014 2015
hélas en 2016 je finis enfin sur cette
grande scène que les années d'avant je
voyais en tant que spectateur et je
monte sur la troisième marche du podium
alors est-ce que j'étais heureux oui
bien sûr est ce que j'ai fait était oui
bien sûr et je me suis dit tout de suite
après bon bain et cie ont gagné alors
2017 arrive je me prépare hélas le néant
aucune motivation aucune aspiration plus
rien
j'ai fait pas mal de compétitions dans
ma vie dans différentes disciplines
jamais gagné j'ai toujours fait 2e 3e 4e
je me suis toujours vu donc bah comme
quelqu'un qui ne pouvaient pas forcément
gagné en plus de ça je suis un petit
artiste vivant sur une petite île dans
un système qui malheureusement ne nous
donne pas vraiment l'envié d'avoir faim
alors je suis là je suis perdu oui c'est
le mot j'étais complètement perdu
jusqu'au jour où j'ai un ami au
téléphone qui habite au canada et qui me
dit alors stick comment ça va terry gou
dans ta préparation et je dis bon mec je
patauge mais je patauge tellement que je
sais même pas où je suis et il me dit
mais tu te souviens quand tu étais venu
à la maison tu avais vu mon miroir dans
la salle de bain et tu avais vu marquer
quinze mille dollars
un an est en fait lui et sa compagne
avaient besoin de 15 mille dollars pour
avancer dans leurs projets et il s'était
donné un an pour réussir et il me dit
mais
pourquoi tu fais que pas comme nous
puisque au bout de 12 mois ont réussi à
voir les 15000 dollars
je me suis dit bon effectivement ça
coûte rien vous imaginez bien qu'en tant
qu'artiste c'est pas les feutres kim eng
à la maison et je vous promets que c'est
vraiment le miroir de chez moi et
d'ailleurs faudrait pas que j'oublie de
le récupérer alors je le fais j'écris
sur mon miroir et je vous promets que
dès le lendemain je sens qu'il se passe
quelque chose quand je rentre dans ma
salle de bain je me vois dans ce miroir
avec ces mots je vous le rideau de ma
douche je rentre dans ma douche je ferme
le rideau et là j'ai l'impression d'être
dans une cabine d'essayage ou je
m'autorise à enfiler mon costume de
champion du monde alors ça se fait pas
tout de suite ça prend quelques jours
j'enfile d'abord ma chaussette puis
l'autre puis le pantalon la chemise
enfin plutôt le short et le t-shirt mais
je m'autorise à porter mon costume de
champion du monde je commence à me voir
en train de peindre le jour de la
compétition
l'inspiration arrive je me vois un bas
de cette scène j'entends mon nom je vois
le trophée je me vois brandir le trophée
je commence à avoir des frissons d'abord
sur une partie de mon corps puis sur le
reste du camp et là je je fais un
transfert dans ma vie sans m'en rendre
compte et l'inspiration revient la
créativité de même et je commence à
peindre encore et encore et encore
jusqu'à ce que je montre dans cet avion
que je parte en autriche et que j'allais
faire ces championnats du monde 2010 est
le jour de la compétition arrive premier
jour après six heures de peinture
délibérations et je suis premier au
classement provisoire
le deuxième jour le jour de la finale
malgré quelques petits couacs
je peins encore et encore et un moment
donné j'entends derrière moi une
personne qui crie time is up
ce qui signifie que le temps imparti est
écoulé qu'il faut s'arrêter je dépose
mon aérographe le petit pistolet de
peinture
j'étais en train de peaufiner des
détails sur mon modèle est donc là je me
relève je prends deux pas de recul de
gdi et j'observe mon modèle
et pour la première fois de ma vie
j'aime ce que je vois et vous savez
c'est comme dans les films il ya tout
qui défile à reculons et en mode
accéléré je revois tout les douches que
j'ai que j'ai prise
alors certes ça faisait des douches très
longue mais je revois tout les 12 que
j'ai prise je revois tous les jours où
j'ai enfilé mon costume toutes les
sensations tout ça m'envahit en un seul
coup et là en fait je comprends en
regardant mon modèle que
que j'ai gagné alors bien entendu je le
dis à personne parce que je crois que ce
que je ressens mais je préférais avoir
les résultats officiels alors j'attends
j'attends quelques heures et après
quelques heures je deviens je deviens
champion du monde de body painting est
aujourd'hui en 2018 je suis double
champion du monde de body painting mon
art aujourd'hui c'est mon métier
parce que oui être artiste c'est un
métier si ça juste pour certaines
personnes mais ce titre de champion du
monde
enfin ces titres de champion du monde
mais moi je me suis pas encore fait à
l'idée m'ont permis d'être bien plus
qu'un professionnel qui fait son travail
ça m'a permis d'avoir confiance en moi
confiance en ma technique savez souvent
les artistes certains se reconnaîtront
peut-être dans cette phrase se pose la
question vais-je réussir à faire ce très
droit parfait sur le dégradé de couleurs
qu'on a mis des heures à faire et que si
on se rate il faut tout recommencer
alors vous inquiétez pas cette question
je me la pose toujours
sauf que maintenant je fais montré et je
me pose la question après aujourd'hui
j'assume ma peinture
j'assume mes idées et ses titres m'ont
permis ça j'ai entend souvent les gens
dire stx et l'artiste qui peint les
femmes c'est exact je ne va pas pour
faire du beau jeu pain pour m'exprimer
dire ce que j'ai au fond de moi je peins
la femme serbe parce que mon message
c'est de contribuer certes à mon échelle
à faire progresser le regard du monde
sur toutes ces inégalités qui existent
entre les hommes et les femmes
malheureusement encore beaucoup trop
présents aujourd'hui en 2018 je peins la
femme dans toute sa diversité
la diversité de la femme c'est quoi
c'est dans ces couleurs comme vous
pouvez le constater quoi de plus
colorimétrique que la femme caribéenne
alors quand je voyage à travers le monde
je lapin pour la faire connaître et deux
pour faire connaître la caraïbe et la
guadeloupe
vous savez cette petite île que beaucoup
de gens ne connaissent pas je peux aussi
la femme
sa diversité c'est aussi dans ces formes
jeux lapin parfois dans ce que la
société nous a défini comme ce qu'est
une belle femme et pour moi aussi une
belle femme c'est une femme avec des
formes avec des courbes avec des
rondeurs je passe sur le corps je peins
sur des toiles mais je peux aussi sur
des murs et ses titres m'ont permis
également aujourd'hui de me sentir
légitime dans mon art et croyez moi la
légitimité dans le graffiti dans le
street art pour employer un autre mot
c'est très important parce que ça amène
le respect et de peindre partout dans la
rue baisse a fait que vous mettez en
danger pour plusieurs raisons la
première raison c'est que une partie de
mes peintures ne sont pas légales et la
deuxième raison c'est que quand vous
peignez dans la rue vous baigner dans la
plus grande galerie du monde
elle est accessible par tout et pour
tous et si vous n'assumez pas vos
peintures
si vous n'êtes pas fiers de ce que vous
faites croyez moi ça va être très très
compliqué et en parlant de fierté il ya
quelques semaines je réalisais une
murale à londres et pendant que j'étais
en train de peindre je voyais qu'avait
une femme kim observés dans au coin de
la rue et elle vient me voir et je vous
promets que c'est elle vraiment j'espère
comment j'ai fait pour avoir cette photo
et elle vient me voir et elle me dit
monsieur excusez moi vous peignez quoi
alors avec mon anglais approximatif
j'essaie de lui faire une réponse elle
me dit c'est pas la peine de me répondre
je sais ce que vous peignez vous peignez
la beauté de la femme
alors madame je sais pas si vous
m'entendez mais merci pour vos mots mais
surtout merci d'avoir compris mon
message
beaucoup de gens me disent oui mais tu
parles la femme c'est normal c'est parce
que tu es un body painter alors c'est
vrai que j'ai un rapport privilégié avec
le corps de la femme mais il faut savoir
que les body painter peine plus souvent
des modèles féminins que masculins parce
que c'est plus difficile de trouver des
hommes qui veuille bien se laisser
peindre d'autant plus par d'autres
hommes
mais je fais du body painting
ça promet
mais je sais que si je peins la femme
aujourd'hui c'est parce que j'ai un
profond respect une énorme admiration
pour ma maman
c'est pas parce que elle m'a élevée
seule alors c'est pas que mon père n'est
pas voulu le faire avec elle c'est juste
qu'il est parti un peu trop tôt et donc
je peins la femme parce que j'ai une
dette envers elle parce qu'elle m'a fait
naître et parce qu'elle m'accompagne
tout ceci toute cette légitimité
cette fierté ses titres me permet
aujourd'hui d'aller encore plus loin
alors j'ai pas dire encore plus haut
encore plus fort mais m'a permis d'aller
encore plus loin et de voir plus grand
souvenez en 2016 quand je vous ai dit
que j'étais monté pour la première fois
sur scène bell était là je pense qu'elle
était contente je vous disais voir plus
grand effectivement alors ceci
malheureusement on voit pas tout mais
pour vous donner une idée la taille de
la bouche que vous voyez c'est à peu
près la taille de mon corps quand je
suis à côté du mur voilà donc la fraise
fait je sais pas combien de mètres mais
elle est grosse a les grandes pardon
donc je disais voilà on voit un peu plus
déjà la taille voir plus grand et
s'assumer ce portrait c'est le portrait
d'une femme que j'ai réalisé sur le plus
gros que j'ai réalisé jusqu'à
aujourd'hui et c'est une femme qui porte
des bijoux qui se reflète ce son visage
sur lequel j'ai intégré le corps d'une
femme nue faut savoir que dans le
quartier où j'ai peint d'ailleurs c'est
ce mur est en guadeloupe si vous voulez
aller le voir c'est à la rue jean jaurès
mais dans le sens inverse de la
circulation donc faudra tourner la tête
parce que beaucoup de gens m'appellent
et me disent oui mon l'a pas vu oui
contre les gros
et il faut savoir que dans ce quartier
le soir il y a une certaine prostitution
qui règne et je me suis dit dans le
concept d'assumer sa peinture d'être
légitime et d'aller toujours plus loin
j'ai voulu écrire un message je voulais
qu'un message parce que je voulais que
les gens comprennent au maximum ce que
je voulais dire
alors ce message le voit si on le voit
un petit peu là le corps d'une femme
n'est pas un objet mais un bijou alors
gym
en fait faut savoir que quand j'ai
publié cette phrase c'est être photos et
ce slogan sur les réseaux sociaux
tous les hommes qui m'ont envoyé des
commentaires qui m'ont appelé avec qui
j'en ai discuté m'ont tous dit stick
hockey ta faute au mur il est au filet
michael ya un problème mais qu'il faut
que tu enlèves ce message tout de suite
ça va pas je comprends pas allah par
contre tu t'es tu est planté et toutes
les femmes avec qui j'ai interagit suite
à ce poste elles m'ont simplement tout
dit merci et la preuve en est ce soir
puisque c'est une femme qui a commencé à
applaudir
n'est ce pas j'étais vue en fait je me
suis rendu compte que tous les hommes
qui avaient interagit avec moi je parle
pas de tous les hommes de la planète
tous les hommes qui avaient interagit
avec moi avait vu le bijoux objets et
que toutes les femmes qui avaient
interagit avec moi avait vu le bijou
précieux
alors merci mesdames d'avoir une
nouvelle fois compris mon message
[Applaudissements]
alors je dis pas que grâce à ma peinture
je vais changer le regard de toutes les
personnes qui verront mes peintures mais
je sais en revanche que je vais toucher
les gens que je vais engendré des
discussions des débats des accords des
désaccords peu importe
mais si grâce à ce mur pour ne parler
que de celui là j'arrive à a changé la
perception même d'une personne bien
franchement pour moi le contrat il sera
entièrement rempli et je me sentirai
ultra heureux parce que j'aurai la
sensation de faire ce pour quoi je suis
fait dans ce monde
alors certains vont me dire bravo aux
sticks il est un peu chiant là il c'est
bon il est double champion du monde il
nous dit qu'il est heureux qu'il ait
machin et tous ces bons il a fini n'ont
jamais fini et je n'aurais jamais fini
j'ai bien l'intention d'enfiler une
nouvelle fois mon costume de champion du
monde parce que j'ai bien l'intention
des trois fois champion du monde et donc
je vais devoir travailler pour ça j'ai
bien l'intention de continuer de pintes
dans la plus grande galerie du monde
mais aussi d'aller dans des galeries un
peu plus conventionnel est de finir dans
des musées j'ai l'intention de voyager
encore plus loin à travers le monde pour
peindre la caraïbe et de pain des murs
encore plus grand et croyez moi j'ai le
vertige
alors oui c'est tout simple et peut-être
bête j'ai écrit deux mots sur un miroir
et ces deux mots m'ont permis de trouver
ma cabine d'essayage et d'enfiler mon
costume de champion du monde
moi j'ai une seule question à vous poser
ce soir à toutes et à tous vous ici
présents présente et vous derrière vos
écrans
demain chez vous
quels costumes allez vous osez porter
merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]